We'll start with a brief discussion on Sigmund Freud, whose ideas are at the
center of psychoanalytic theory. Now psychoanalytic therapy is the original
form of talk therapy. It's oriented towards major personality change with a
focus on uncovering unconscious sexual and aggressive motives, especially
through dream interpretation. He believed that each dream was an attempt to
fulfill unacceptable desires or satisfy unconscious impulses, thoughts,
feelings, and drives. Freud believed that dreams were the royal road to the
unconscious. A key technique developed by Freud for interpreting dreams and
getting at the unconscious motives was free association. This is when a patient
says absolutely every association he or she has about an image in a dream, no
editing allowed. Then the therapist helps interpret the dream through the
symbolic meaning the associations have. When effective, dream interpretation
uncovers unconscious conflicts, and this in turn can alleviate neurotic
symptoms.